yeah he resigned a little bit maybe  did you see queen takes night  when he resigned no i mean  but it's problem  when i come to board i see something  going wrong i mean  face of chess players also  such as players i think everyone said  this queen f3  only not me  but  but its problem is  of course i have time so i need to think  because you attack my rookie i need to  take e1 because normally i calculate  rookie 838 queen b5  it's best  not the first queen b5 i think take e8  take queen b5 to attack b7 pawn but then  same queen f3 is made same yeah i mean  same mate  but after rookie one take the queen  before here is here i asked why he  resigned yeah because it's strange  and he asked me you don't see this one